hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before
friday monday morning podcast and ah
i'm just checking in on you i'm just
checking in
to see how you're doing how your week
is going along are you worried about the
variant
are you not worried about the variant
you know what is happening with you i
know what's going on in milwaukee
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen congratulations to
the 2021
nba champions your milwaukee bucks
and they've been waiting 50 years
so i'm gonna say it again
congratulations
to the 20 21 nba
champions your milwaukee bucks what a
run
who goes down two games to none and then
runs the [ __ ] table you're milwaukee
bucks who keeps you dying on the vine
for half a [ __ ] century before they
win the next one
your milwaukee bucks
who saw that tub of [ __ ] with the
[ __ ]
basketball jersey and a giant flabby arm
that made her look like a grandmother
and she was still in the 20s
because it was full of brats your
milwaukee bucks fan base
who probably created a new variant
of the [ __ ] corona virus with 60 000
strong with no mass or condoms
probably your milwaukee bucks fan base
jesus christ they should have put
[ __ ] covid in liquid form and just
put it into a crop duster and just
[ __ ] flown right over that goddamn
crowd
flowing around would you tear young i
would hold my breath you ain't gonna
[ __ ] with my freedom
i have the freedom to ignore science
i have the freedom
to to ignore common sense
i talked to somebody today and they were
going like you know i go well you didn't
like what happened with polio she goes
hey not for nothing you know
uh i got a friend of mine and uh her kid
got the polio shot and he had to drag
his legs for two years i was like
alright so the kid had a reaction
other than that it went pretty [ __ ]
good
right it's so [ __ ] dumb
this i don't trust i don't trust you're
full of [ __ ]
that you don't trust it because i'll
tell you right now if the if the [ __ ]
if they came out with a shot that gave
you a flat stomach and abs
all of these same people ain't [ __ ]
my freedom they'd be
right down there getting that [ __ ]
thing because all of those fat
[ __ ] they go in for that lap band
surgery
they go in for that [ __ ] knowing they
could die they don't give a [ __ ] go get
me some abs
you know open heart surgery people die
all the [ __ ] time on the operating
table
if you need it you're not going to get
it there's always going to be an example
of something that
you know that went wrong
i mean the patriots drafted a [ __ ]
tight end and he turned out to be a mass
murderer
what are we never gonna [ __ ] draft
another tight end what the [ __ ] are we
doing here
you go out to a bar you hit on some
chicks you get turned down you go home
you have to jerk off
are you never going to hit on women
again does that mean hitting on women
does it lead to getting laid at some
point
according to these people it does
what would you do
um part of me is starting to think like
you know what i think just some people
don't have a dream or their dream died
so
the only thing that they have is killing
other people's dreams
of getting on with their lives and
making money
you know or maybe it like the government
telling them what to do
taps into how much they hated as a child
that they had to listen to their parents
and how much they hated when they got
into high school they scared you you
need two
two years of a language you gotta have
this if you don't you need an
extracurricular activity
do you remember the first night when you
were on your own
i mean i'm talking like with me
i commuted to college right
i paid for most of my college i had to
work through all of that i
[ __ ] pulled myself up by my
bootstraps i'm better than all of you
um i [ __ ] uh
my first time being alone
i moved out when i was 27.
i moved out briefly when i was 20 and
then i had to go back to school so i
couldn't afford it
so i had to work and [ __ ] do all of
that [ __ ] so and it took me forever to
get through college because i can only
afford to go part-time
boo hoo boo [ __ ] who then i became a
[ __ ] comedian
then i knew i was going to move to new
york so i wasn't going to move out and
blow all my money on some stupid [ __ ]
apartment
in boston i stayed at home like a
[ __ ] loser
and saved up enough money where i could
survive that first [ __ ] year
of ridiculously high rent and
um and then hopefully i'd be in clubs
and making enough money where i could
swing
my rent which is what happened but when
i moved down there
27 i remember the first night i was
hanging at the comic strip
lucian had basically already told me i
already have enough white guys
you and your dream can go right back to
boston it's not going to happen
you know if i was some white chick and
there was twitter i could have got him
fired for that
uh but instead i just worked harder um
anyway i uh
i remember that night sitting at the bar
thinking at 27 i remember thinking
clearly like you know what
i don't have to go home i don't have to
do whatever i want i could do what i can
get [ __ ] drunk right now
if i knew how to talk to women i could
bring abroad home i could get a [ __ ]
i don't know whatever the [ __ ] i want to
eat eat it
watch tv i can do whatever the [ __ ] i
want
you know i thought instead i was like
you know what i should do i should go
home and get some sleep
wake up tomorrow and write some [ __ ]
jokes because the clock is ticking
and i'm going to run out of money
eventually in this [ __ ] city that's
what i did
you know that was an analogy
to tell you to go home and get your rest
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about but uh
congratulations also to the phoenix suns
on an amazing amazing run
you can't hang your heads even though
you're up two games to none it [ __ ]
happens
[ __ ] i remember the 86 red sox we're up
two games to none
we won the first two in new york
shea stadium i still remember coming
home getting out of my car
my neighbor just came home and i and we
were teenagers i remember galloping
sideways in a circle
with him jumping up and down thinking we
were going to win it and we [ __ ] lost
it
so it happens every year you know
whatever 30 29 30 teams don't win it
only one team does i
don't subscribe to this they didn't win
because this guy blew it
this guy never gets it done
uh you know
i was watching jim rome and he was kind
of getting on chris paul a little bit
they you know he's never done he's the
only guy that this is the third
or fourth time being up two games a
number he's lost his series
and it's like i don't think chris paul
is your problem
he's one of the best players in the
league
like is it his problem that he can't
drag the rest of the guys over the
[ __ ] wall
you're gonna you're gonna go after the
star player i've just never understood
that
but he was just saying that it's a
pretty wild stat i've never [ __ ]
you know no one else has a thing but
it's just like well you know
here's another wild stat you're the only
guy i ever seen get tipped over in a
chair in his own show i still watch you
i don't think you're not getting it done
but that's a pretty wild stat
all the people that have done sports
shows i've never seen a guy have the
guests
tip him over in a [ __ ] chair after
basically
an eight-year-old on a playground
argument
i bet you won't i bet i will go ahead do
it and then he does i mean
it was embarrassing for that set men
back like [ __ ] i don't know what but
i don't think he shouldn't have a show
and i don't think
that he doesn't get it done i've just
never understood that
we didn't win the championship let's go
after the best players let's go after
the reason
why we're here um
i've never understood that but i mean i
think that that's that's just the way it
works
so anyway let's talk diet um
went a little off the diet i'm not gonna
lie lady and i didn't go to the gym
yesterday i had to take a day off at
some point
i just woke up you know oh billy post
mushrooms
going to therapy he's been dealing with
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
unpacking as they said and uh
i just you know i just didn't feel like
[ __ ] doing anything yesterday i was
like you know what we'll put me in a
good mood
what if i just cancel a bunch of [ __ ]
and i have a nice daddy daughter date
that's what i'm gonna do so instead i
took my lovely daughter out
and we went uh we went to a park and she
rode a bike and she went to the
the playground put on her masks
and you know it's funny she's like dad
the slides are too hot
i was like all right let's ride the bike
more she was chasing me and i was
you know running after her and all that
stuff it was just awesome and then we
went out
and got some ice cream and they said do
you want a kid scoop or an adult scoop i
said it kid scoop but it's one of these
old school places
so even a kid scoop the [ __ ] scoop of
ice cream was as big as my daughter's
head
so i ended up finishing what she didn't
eat which is the first time i've had ice
cream in like a month
and i just sort of hung out with my wife
and kids all day
and i took two naps kind of needed it
and now today i'm [ __ ] back on it
where my day i just woke up
made the breakfast which i love doing
i'm teaching my daughter how to make
waffles
because she loves them then i did a
record for the
fifth and final season of afters for
family
i did a little bit of therapy now i'm
knocking out this podcast right before i
do the
uh anything better podcast with version
then i'm going to the gym
i'm getting back on the [ __ ]
elliptical when i get on the elliptical
i'm looking at my [ __ ] flash carts
for this instrument test which by the
way i flew
uh five times and over the last week
and i've probably done anywhere between
10 and 15
instrument approaches missed approaches
holds and all of that
and i i've gotten to the point where i
now get it
i'm not behind the aircraft except for
the uh
the vor ones i sometimes i i forget to
look at the clock or set the clock for
my minutes
going down before you get to the missed
approach point
and uh but i flew with this other guy
who who told me the trick
of control your altitude with your power
which i was doing with my cyclic which
is a [ __ ] that's what's a stick but
you know between your legs as opposed to
the thing that looks like an emergency
brake for those of you who don't fly
helicopters right
so and you're able to just lock it in
and then you just don't move the
collective and then you're just locked
in on this attitude and you come right
down
and on a precision approach when you
come out and you end up looking up
you know with your stupid [ __ ]
foggles on
uh and the runway you're like dead
center right down the middle and i just
been having an absolute blast i
understand all the avionics
in my uh helicopter now and i gotta tell
you like i landed yesterday
or two days ago and i i just felt like a
pilot for the first time ever
like uh you know because we ended up
doing like an auto rotation
and i did a really great auto and i was
just like i just [ __ ]
i i'm feeling one with this thing uh
which is beyond exciting and i am now
obsessed with approach plates
like i was looking at them for like
major airports like logan airport in
boston and just seeing all the different
ways of coming in and
and i can tell the difference between
the uh
if i need to be in vor or in gps it's
[ __ ] wild man
i can't believe after you know that i
got all of that in there
in the in the old hard drive so i'm very
excited about that
um i'm excited to not be uh
you know my wife freaked out the other
day when all that cnn [ __ ] was going
on
which i [ __ ] up was because usually
whenever i trash one i always trash the
other but that time i didn't so fox news
picked it up isn't that funny which
really proved my point
that it's really not news because if it
was news they would have brought that up
when i was also criticizing them along
with cnn
sort of fascinating but my wife actually
started to read it it's just like yeah
it's it's not going to be in the news
it's going to go away okay 911
went away that was on the front page
for like two weeks and eventually that
one if that went away
if that [ __ ] tragedy went away
i i really gotta think after a couple
days my
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] i said on a
podcast is gonna go away
because she started to read it i don't
[ __ ] listen to that [ __ ] your [ __ ]
version of what you think i said
um
but anyway um
really excited though getting back to
the milwaukee bucks man what a
performance
ante de campo middleton holiday the
whole [ __ ] team
um i really needed that white guy to hit
those last two foul shots and he didn't
you know what i mean there is something
about watching the nba you know
where it's exciting and then as a white
guy sometimes you get low self-esteem
it's like jesus christ can get the
[ __ ] rebound hit the three can you
hit the three i'm not talking about
european white guys i'm going to say it
okay american white guys
need to step it up that's actually not
true because that white kid on [ __ ]
milwaukee kills it
i'm sorry on on miami kills it i don't
know the names
all right i don't pretend to know the
[ __ ] names
uh i used to know names i used to name
names
but i just don't have i don't have the
[ __ ] bandwidth anymore with the kids
um
so anyway so i'm gonna hit the gym after
this i'm actually oh billy pull downs
so i can eventually do a pull-up um
getting back to that my shoulder feels
great
i've been stretching i've been playing
drums
uh i've been playing along to that
mammoth album
the wolfgang van halen album loving that
and he played the drums on that dude
he's a [ __ ] badass drummer too with a
killer foot
so i've been having a good time with
that and uh i don't know i think
yesterday
i had i got like that [ __ ] catholic
guilt does anybody else have that
the [ __ ] catholic guilty if you
actually take a day off
i could be doing something right now
dude i laid around like a [ __ ]
goddamn grizzly bear yesterday i didn't
do
[ __ ] well i guess i took my kid to the
park but
um i do remember when i was
eating ice cream with her and i was kind
of sitting there
and i was just thinking like this is
what when you know someday when i'm
laying on my deathbed this is what i'm
going to think about
is that i did this and i'll be happy
that i did this
as opposed to uh like going over there i
gotta get this done i gotta do
that i gotta get better at this and i
just like
she [ __ ] relax there freckles
don't just sit down long enough to have
a little bit of sunspots on top of your
[ __ ] head there
jesus christ that's all i do is i just
wake up and i just start [ __ ]
running around like a lunatic you know
what i did do the other day
which for any other people out there
shave their head you know which is
[ __ ] great uh
if you have a [ __ ] shaved head and
you're on an elliptical
is to have the headband you know
on your head man it's the best then you
don't have to [ __ ] slow down and
towel off your head you know
every three minutes after you've been on
it for like you know 10 12 minutes and
it just becomes you know
pouring down your face it's actually
great
i had it on my wife was on the treadmill
and she was just laughing at me i was
like
i know i look like an [ __ ] but it
works um another great thing about
getting old you don't care what you look
like
[Laughter]
it's over you're over the hill and you
know it's just gonna get worse so as bad
as somebody thinks she looks
you know that this is the best you're
going to look from now into the future
you're over the hill right there you go
well geez bill you explained something
we already understood
um all right well i want to thank
everybody for buying tickets
for august 11th at the uh the wilber
theater
um i'm gonna get to send off my buddy uh
the great wayne previtty in style it's
actually become
a benefit slash
um reunion
where i you know reached out to all of
these comics that uh
you know i started out with and i'm
trying to put together a
show where uh
i'm recreating a a lineup from like
25 years ago even more than that
between 25 and 30 years ago we used to
do stand up at the the 99s
in bel ricka and john david got the room
and it was such a huge gig
for my whole generation and the
generation before me
like coming up it was such a [ __ ]
huge gig
because it gave us this stage time
and it was not easy stage time because
it was not an easy gig it was just this
giant stage as far as like
it wasn't long it was just really high
and you would walk up there and you'd
stand up there
and there was this big bar
and i remember oh god i still it's still
vivid to me
and on and all of these people would uh
be talking and drinking and watching the
game the worst is when they would
put the sound down on like a bruins game
and you'd go up there and these [ __ ]
people were just losing their minds
yelling at you
and uh this guy john david booked it but
by learning how to handle that room
it set you on your path
to all the hell room gigs that you were
gonna have to work and i remember i used
to watch
these guys come in and close it
because that was like the paid spot was
the the actual professional comic would
come in after all of us
you know open micros or just sort of
openers or whatever
that like still worked for free you know
to figure [ __ ] out
they would come in and they would close
it out doing like a half hour
and all of these guys like chris mcguire
now who's
got a huge writing career out here
hollywood uh
who else paul nardisi and steve bjork i
used to watch all of these guys come in
and close it out you just sit there
watching like it was the second they
walked on stage like the
even the bar just sensed that somebody
that knew what they were doing was on
stage and
they just immediately they had this
sense of poise and control
and i remember i would watch it
trying to absorb it but not
understanding what they were doing
because i didn't know how to do it
but i would really
go back in that moment to still being a
fan of like stand-up which i still am
but like
i almost became like a crowd member
audience member where i would just sit
there and watch these guys go up
and kill in this room that was like
you know kicking my ass most of the
times and there was nothing better that
when you went up and you actually had a
good set
if you had a good setup that was so
funny like you would actually get a
little bit of a buzz
around boston in in like your thing like
hey man i heard you killed at the 99s
you know who'd you follow what was your
spot like everyone wanted to know like
the the
the stats who did you go on after how
far into the show were you
and um i particularly remember that show
always hanging out in the parking lot
with all of the guys that i'm going to
be working with
on august 11th and we would be talking
about uh
you know comics and and and around town
and famous comedians
and uh i don't know our dreams of what
the hell we wanted to do right in that
parking lot and i think the 99 of bill
rick is i wonder if that's still there i
got to look that up i'm sure if i went
there
30 years they [ __ ] redid it it's
probably not the same
which brings you back to that expression
you can never go home which i didn't
understand i was like we're talking
about go home all the time
it's not going to be the same people and
they're going to redo the [ __ ] 99.
99 restaurant
belricka mass get the [ __ ] out of here
oh they got two look at them
right let me click on this i don't know
this is the
will let me do the satellite some reason
the google [ __ ] let's see google
map it's the one that had the giant
drove down a hill and had a giant
parking lot
all right wait a second what am i doing
here
it's it's really amazing how long i've
had a computer and how little i know how
to [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
how come i can't go satellite here
yeah it gives a [ __ ] it's one of those
things root three
that's back when you had to like write
down
you had to write down the [ __ ] uh
directions
long time ago i'm trying to find oh god
there's a picture of the awful food
i don't see any picture inside the
restaurant
like i said i'm sure it [ __ ] changed
since way back then i'm really just
babbling aren't i just going down
[ __ ] memory memory lane here
um all right let me do a little bit of
advertising reads here
um by the way i'm down to a buck 80 and
change
i'm almost in the 170s so get your
[ __ ] fat shaming in soon
because pretty soon when i get down to a
buck 78 hopefully by sunday
then i'm only gonna be according to the
body
mass index index index
index i'll only be five pounds
overweight but i'm also at the
top they said i can be from 129
all the way up to 173 yeah i'm another
slice
um the whole gamut all right roman
everybody
most guys have tried different ways to
last longer
but thinking about baseball doesn't
always work
um the folks at roman can you mention
thinking about baseball in 86 when the
red sox blew it to the mets
while you're banging your wife
i can't accidentally choke around the
folks at roman
and online men's health company are
changing the game with roman
swipes the secret to longer lasting sex
roman swipes are a clinically proven way
to last longer in bed
they're effective easy to use and fast
acting
but don't require prescription roman can
ship swipes to you in a discrete
unmarked piece number
it's not going to say that in discrete
unmarked packaging
and each swipes packet is small enough
to hide your wallet for whenever you
need it
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your partner so you can last
longer without worrying
i'm just picturing your dick like an
elephant trunk just [ __ ]
drinking the water just drinks up the
numbness is that what happens
just absorbs it so quickly uh they're
super easy to use
like evidently it dries up like [ __ ]
jet fuel just take the swipes out of the
packet
swipe it on let it dry and you're good
to go that's it
go to getroman.com get ten dollars off
your first order of swipes
plus free two-day shipping that's
getroman.com
ten dollars off your first order of
swipes plus free two-day shipping
um why can't you just own up and just
say listen i'm not gonna lie to you i
come really fast
okay but i can get back in the game real
quick
all right i'm right back in it's like a
[ __ ]
f1 pit stop i'll be right back in the
game and then you know i'll last a
little longer
and you know uh we'll do three for the
price of one okay hopefully i'll get you
there by the third one
you know what i mean when i got flop
sweat on my face all right liquid death
everybody
uh they told me not to read the copy
evidently they don't like the way i read
or so i think they're telling everybody
not to read the copy basically liquid
you know these [ __ ] plastic bottles
that they put the uh the water in they
last for 800 to a thousand years
all right it's 120 130 degrees out
you know we got to stop doing this i've
been i've used one plastic bottle in the
last
month and i've been doing stand-up like
a maniac i literally bring like a
thermos with me
my water at home or i just grab a liquid
death
because it is made uh they stick it in
an aluminum can it looks like a bud tall
uh it liquid death also donates 10
of their profits to help kill plastic
pollution forever
i think you know at this point we can't
keep blaming the big companies or expect
them to do anything about it
i think uh if we act as individuals
they'll see that this is the direction
people are going in and then they'll see
dollar signs and maybe they'll actually
help clean up their act uh you can get
these wonderful cans of water
and biodegradable cans that will uh at
whole foods or 7-eleven and also i'll
tell you it tastes better
taste but water and glass or aluminum or
anything that just tastes better than
just [ __ ] in plastic plus i heard
they'd sit in the warehouse for like
[ __ ]
years anyway uh you get a special deal
through me go to liquiddeth.com
to get a free set of koozies with your
first order
or any case of water and while you're
waiting uh for your free
koozies to arrive grab some liquid death
at any whole foods or 7-eleven
that's liquiddeth.com to get a free set
of koozie
and your first order of any case of
water grab some cans now
and completely murder your thirst that's
what i've been doing i am completely
off of water bottles i have to figure
out a way to do this when i'm
on the road and i'm thinking the way to
do it is i'll just buy some liquid death
while i'm out there
i might just put it in my rider because
they're at like whole foods which i
think are around
you know what i'm gonna [ __ ] do that
right now i'm gonna send that out
to my my agent there give him something
to [ __ ] worry about extra like oh
jesus
he's becoming a diva look at him flies a
couple of good instrument approaches and
then all of a sudden you can't tell this
guy a goddamn thing
um all right everybody that is the
podcast i'm coming up against it
here before i go do the uh the versi
podcast once again congratulations to
the city of milwaukee
and uh all of their amazing fans i mean
60 000 people showed up to just stand
outside and party i mean talk about like
i mean that is a that is a [ __ ] fan
base man
um i actually went to a home game there
a long time ago and they played like the
[ __ ] bradley center or something like
that and that was
that was probably the early 2000s late
90s early 2000s sort of the depths
of the milwaukee bucks drought
kind of almost halfway through it if a
little bit more but um
it's just great for the city and
congratulations to the phoenix suns
uh on an amazing series an amazing run
and all of that uh they got a great team
and they got nothing to be ashamed of
and they they will be back
that's what i think that's what i'm
thinking that and i'm [ __ ] sticking
with it all right
enjoy the music picked out by the other
greek freak andrew themilis
and we're gonna have a bonus half hour
of material and that material of a a
bonus episode
of uh the thursday afternoon just before
friday
monday morning podcast all right
i hope all you guys have a great couple
of days and a great weekend your [ __ ]
and uh that's it i'll talk to you later
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
july 22nd
2013. off we go
into the wild blue yonder
flying high into the sky
ah [ __ ] i got a bunch of [ __ ] to do
today people
just like you even my mondays are busy
i actually got a lot of [ __ ] out of the
way already i walk my dog around the
block
it took a [ __ ] i picked it up
i in a bag all right
unlike that rappaport fella i picked it
up right
and i put it in somebody's barrel
somebody else's barrel
which is the right thing slash douchey
thing to do the ultimate neighborly
thing is you pick it up and you hold on
to it
you get back to your own trash can and
then you put it in there that right
there
that is a class act all right then you
have tier two you have me well at least
he picked it up but then the [ __ ]
threw it in my trash barrel i can argue
well hey you know
it's a trash barrel what are you worried
that it's just gonna smell like rotting
garbage
is this [ __ ] smell really gonna ruin it
but i understand there's a principle
it's your dog it's your [ __ ] um
you know then you have the last ones the
people who just don't pick it up
but anyways anyways people been breaking
into cars in my neighborhood man it's
[ __ ]
every once in a while like just they'll
come by here for a while and they leave
la's really a weird city
where it's like you live in a place and
one night it's safe and then the next
night it isn't you know there's the
general vibe and then there's also like
the [ __ ] roulette
aspect of living in los angeles so i
think they come by
they [ __ ] with cars because it's the
same people right
it's five of them it's five people
running the world and there's five
people breaking all the windows
and stealing [ __ ] in this car i'm
convinced of it all right
i have i have i have information that
can back that up if you want it i'll
give it to you
but i would appreciate it if you've been
listening my podcast long enough that
you would just take me
at my own with my word actually means
something to you
you know um anyways they've been
breaking in these [ __ ] cars and uh
that's just annoying i told you to have
me last time they [ __ ] there was
nothing in my car
and then they took all my quarters those
little satchel recorders
for the parking meters because i still
don't want to use my credit card because
i don't want to tell people where the
[ __ ] i am
you know
well according to your your your [ __ ]
parking meter records you you were there
sir
and i know it right now dude they can
just track you with your cell phone man
um maybe they can
but i could say well i lost my cell
phone someone else had it right
i could come around with it but if he
[ __ ] could say somebody stole my
credit card
i don't know i don't like people
watching me all the [ __ ] time
you know you know what kills me is the
amount of people that actually are happy
snowden did what he did and there's
nobody any anywhere in media
with any sort of a [ __ ] job that pays
any
decent amount of money that is opening
their [ __ ] mouse
everybody's keeping quiet good for you
snowden
keep running you can stay at my house if
you want to
hang out till you know it blows over you
know
sit around eat some tv dennis hey you
know what i did this week everybody
i uh i went out and i bought the the
body issue
the naked issue the nude issue of espn
why because i'm a pervert yes
why because i always like the 49ers but
wanted to see their quarterback
completely naked
in the on some lava rocks absolutely you
got me
i can't remember how many times last
year when i was watching a 49ers game
you know
this colin kaepernick i'll tell you he's
entertaining to watch but you know it
would be more entertaining
if somehow he would get down on all
fours on some [ __ ] lava rocks
like he's going to uh do a 100 yard dash
into the ocean that's what i would
really like
no you know why i bought it because
somebody told me gary player was on the
cover
that's what i was told am i gary player
isn't that guy like [ __ ] 100 years
old they're like no he's like 77.
you know and they go he's in
unbelievable shape you know me
i'm obsessed with not becoming a fat
[ __ ]
right fat people call that having a body
issue
you know because they don't want to stop
eating their jelly and ritz crackers
late at night you know that they stuff
into ice cream
you know what's funny is as mean as i am
to fat people i've slowly begun to and
just according to this guy last week and
i'll take him as
is like every fat person who listens to
this i'm beginning to shame people
into losing weight and i think that that
would be a great show
it would be just like biggest loser as
far as the amount of yelling
but it wouldn't be as motivational it'll
be like the opposite
and then it would cause a controversy
and then there would be people doing
that split screen on tv you know you got
the host and then you got the two people
like uh
you know well what do you think uh
person i've never heard of before
well i think it's great you know i think
these fat [ __ ] uh that's about time
somebody called them a fat
[ __ ] what do you think about a female uh
person who of course you have to have
the motherly side of this
well i just think that people have to
understand
that it's a food addiction this negative
reinforces we're seeing this in schools
with boy oh [ __ ] you lady okay i think
you can lose a couple of pounds to it
hey hey hey let's try to keep it nice
all right let's try like the [ __ ]
host
who's exploiting the whole problem can
then sit there rubbing his chin
shaking his head you know you know it's
funny all three of them
in that moment they're all getting paid
they're all making money
off of the lard that's in the asses of
so many people these days
and i i like to think that that's the
true uh tragedy
you know i like to think right now that
i'm thinking outside the box
the ice box i guess i guess you would
call it what's the deal
um so i got the body
issue and uh you know what bugged me
this [ __ ] trend like the [ __ ]
tattoos
um that people have you know what it is
in particular what is it in particular
bill i don't like people who write
[ __ ] inspirational [ __ ] on their body
like you know and they always have it in
a place you know they don't always but
for a lot of times they have it in a
[ __ ] place where only i can really
get a good look at it
so there's no way for me not to take
that is like what do you think i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you have life all
figured out
that you know you got to write this [ __ ]
on your body where the hell is it
where the hell is this [ __ ] person
who was this [ __ ] golfer
beautiful woman right in like a 1950s
kind of way you know little houses
and they're all made out of ticky tacks
and we [ __ ] missionary only two have
more kids
they have blue eyes they have brown eyes
and they all say
[ __ ] racist [ __ ] but it's the 1950s
and nobody knows better
sorry um
that's a water fountain it's just for us
it's the 19 [ __ ] 50s
so this woman that's some of the worst
singing i've ever done
woof that even sounded bad to me so this
is [ __ ] lady
her name is uh carly booth gorgeous
little diesel
she's sitting there on the driving range
looks like in manhattan
driving some golf balls i'm sure people
going by in their [ __ ] yachts
you know all upset going why is that
that naked woman playing golf and i
wasn't invited to that party i don't
have enough money
i thought i knew bloomberg too so anyway
she has written on the side of her body
all right it's uh starts at her waist
and then goes down to whatever that that
piece of meat is that's between uh it's
at the same level as your ass cheek
your side side of your hip i guess you'd
call it right
is that what it's called in the uh the
medical field so anyways this beautiful
woman has something
i can't even read the first it looks
like the symbol for pie i don't know
what it is
she has written on the side of her body
it says whatever
is not oh jesus christ i can't read this
whatever is not the stars to hold our
destinies
but in ourselves or our destiny i can't
read it it's too far away
but i just don't know why why do why do
people do that
is that for when she's hooking up with
some guy right and he's banging her
doggy style
and he kind of leans over and he looks
and then he reads that and like what's
he supposed to think that
right like damn this [ __ ] is deep
they're endless guys get them too
you know trying to be a little fair a
little more fair and balanced
in the spirit of fox news here where i
totally lean one way but i try to just
say i'm fair and balanced let's let's
let's
let's search this right now shall we um
tattoo sayings all right click
on there we got some images here
all right oh look at all these beautiful
girls with sentences
it's like not only do you get to enjoy
their beauty they get to help you out
with life
let's see what we got here let's view
all images
we'll make them bigger you [ __ ] all
right this gorgeous woman
she's doing that thing where she puts
her thumb in her [ __ ] uh
belt loop and pulls her jeans down a
little bit that's like the classic when
you have like the bathing suit
edition of sports illustrated you always
got to have like
for you future women out there or male
models i think guys can get away with it
too what you do is you're totally naked
you have little speedos on
and you're not showing enough skin so
then you got to take a thumb
you stick it in the side of it you pull
it down a little bit and then you have
this look on your face like what
did something happen um
all right she has on her side fall down
seven times
stand up eight i
just if you're truly a strong person you
know can't you just
you know hear that just like remember it
i am enough the way i am this woman has
this written on her
uh collar bone and it goes right into
the uh the ball and socket joint there
whatever the [ __ ] you call it
huh the ball joint there and your
shoulder
i am enough the way i am
you know like i see that all i want to
do
is just give her a hug pat her on the
head and just be like i'm sorry
your parents did whatever they did to
you i'm sorry they didn't say the things
they needed to say um all right what
does this person have
no that's written in french so you know
what's pretentious
um
infinite i don't know why you would have
that on there
this is my favorite one this guy has
this written on his wrist
take a chance they don't come much
bigger than this
you know so whatever the situation is
be it he he meets the girl of his dreams
or some hooker who doesn't have
a condom he looks down at his wrist and
that's what it says right
i don't know is this bombing i was in
heaven i was in hell
believe in neither but fear them as well
damn were you really in heaven and were
you in hell
here on earth or did you visit another
land
he's [ __ ] jerk off he probably
unloads trucks he had it written on the
back of his calf right you're just a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know just you should have said
[ __ ] and then a [ __ ] arrow pointed
right up at your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know all you pretentious [ __ ]
with your [ __ ] song lyrics and crap
on your body can you put them in a place
where we don't have to look at what i
don't have to look at i'm going to speak
for everybody
all right that guy if i was a dictator
if i was running [ __ ]
all right after i assassinated or
imprisoned
or pistol-whipped every [ __ ] banker i
could find
i would then be like all right you have
two options
you either get that [ __ ] thing
removed
all right or you never wear shorts again
you're allowed to wear your underwears
when you walk around your apartment but
that's it
other than that go [ __ ] yourself
look at these [ __ ] people every new
beginning
comes from some other beginnings end
oh geez wow i never looked at it that
way thank god you wrote that on your rib
cage
would you like another fuzzy navel
[Music]
oh my god this girl's got an entire
story written on her back
i just love this passage and i always
wanted to have it written on my back
all right the shoulder blade tattoo
what has she got here what does this one
say
there's a lot of women with uh [ __ ]
written on their backs in different
languages
all right here's to me here's to you and
here's to life and laughter
i'll be true as long as you and not a
single moment after
jesus christ
what and it literally looks like she
wrote it on her back and had someone
else
fill it in here's to me here's the other
god love never fails
all right this guy's getting written on
both forums i listen to the
i listen to the bray of my heart i
am i am i am oh my god dude these are
like
you know the thing i like about this
[ __ ] that they write in on their bodies
is that's just a great thing to read
during your during a first date all
right here's one for you if you if you
meet a girl with a foot tattoo
like you got to go in another direction
right
there's nothing uglier than a foot
tattoo they just did
you just i don't understand i don't
understand
you know what i'm sure there's a lot of
you guys out there probably most of you
at this point have tattoos right
you know at what point are those things
going to go out of style
has this podcast just completely lost
momentum i feel like lenny bruce when he
[ __ ] just kept reading his uh
his court cases i really got way too
into that tattoo i just [ __ ]
enough i'm enough with the tattoos
every [ __ ] athlete that stupid issues
got some big
dumbass piece on their back of their
shoulders and you know what i gotta be
honest with you
it all looks the same bunch of squibbly
squibs squabbly dudes there's always a
fish or a [ __ ] dragon in there
you know the [ __ ] is wrong with you
everybody else has one i want one too
it's one of the greatest things i ever
did was i never got a [ __ ] tattoo
back you know it's funny back when uh
when i was when i was just a lad
and you got tattoos people it was the
tail end of getting like cartoon
characters like just about four inches
away from your dick
you know you get it like you i mean
there was a guy had you sent me sam
with the two guns and said back off it
was just to the right of his package
you know i knew another guy he got the
[ __ ] budweiser label
that's what you got you know you didn't
sit there and have to be like [ __ ]
you know a stitch in time saves the
sorcerer who gets up early and catches
the worm
yeah a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what keep getting your tattoos i like it
you know it's branding you
as someone not worthy of talking to
um can you guys do that for me this
weekend can you walk around when you see
people who have those and when you just
read them just point at them
like you're in that invasion of the body
snatcher and just go oh
[ __ ] damn and then [ __ ] walk away
no don't do that don't you know what
don't even listen to me
um all right the [ __ ] was i going to
talk about this
oh guess what i did this week oh freckle
face bill guess what i did you know a
year ago i rode a [ __ ] motorcycle or
whatever i went dirt bike riding
i actually took a motorcycle safety
course it was uh
it was a day and a half and i got to
tell you man it was [ __ ]
uh exhilarating and terrifying
so i actually i passed the class somehow
i don't think i should have
i was doing my little u-turns i had to
put my little foot down there
um no it's a great [ __ ] time
so basically how it worked was you rode
for like four hours and then you had a
class
um and i realized how spoiled i am as a
[ __ ] human being
you know just having this the life that
i have where i don't have a boss and i
basically do whatever the [ __ ] i want i
have not been in a classroom
um and i just immediately i just
takes me back to why i chose the route i
chose i just
never liked the classroom situation but
this this was uh was actually a great
time
but i just immediately had anxiety and
i'm like half paying attention and then
and then in the end they're like okay
now we're going to do the test and i
went right back to when i was like in
eighth grade
like oh god i'm gonna fail this the
guy's like no one has ever failed this
and you're like oh good
pressure pressure i'm a [ __ ] we're
sitting at the table and everybody's
[ __ ]
finishing before i was like there was
like i don't know
40 people in the class i think i
finished 37th
as far as completing the test um
i know this is 50 questions i got four
wrong
i think something like that i don't
[ __ ] know but somehow i passed and um
that was funny i've never flip-flopped
so much in my life on a decision i was
thinking am i going to get a bike
should i just get a dirt bike should i
just know how to do this
and then you know i just want to learn
how to ride a motorcycle
you know i grew up in the 80s all right
i watched a lot of action movies and one
of the things that i always was envious
of the action heroes
aside from their oiled up [ __ ] 80s
lifting weights no squats ever bodies
was
uh the fact that no matter what vehicle
they approached not only were the keys
always in it
they knew how to drive it they knew how
to drive everything from a dump truck to
a [ __ ] helicopter
airplane they could sail they could
[ __ ] do anything so
you know it's coming up where you know
we got to raise the debt ceiling again
eventually the waves gonna hit the beach
and there's going to be a period where
you could quite possibly
be getting chased down the street by an
angry [ __ ] mob
is just everything goes to [ __ ]
you know so at that point it would be
nice
if you had the ability to whatever
escape vehicle you meet
you ran into you could actually just
jump in and just be all right with it
right sylvester stallone
[ __ ] uh uh arnold schwarzenegger
steven seagal chuck norris they never
and i challenge you to find anything
that they [ __ ] ran up to in any of
those movies
that they did not jet ski [ __ ]
motorboat
sailboat submarine combine helicopter
[ __ ] plane with with only can land on
water
those skis or the tires doesn't make a
difference
they could instrument rated the
everything
everything they could be on a [ __ ]
plane a commercial airline
and somehow kill the person next to them
put a hat over their face without
anybody noticing
crawl down into where the luggage is and
then jump off the landing gear and do a
[ __ ]
mosh at the end of the the
the runway they were unstoppable so i've
added motorcycle
all right i could drive a car stick or
regular
and now i can drive a motorcycle i'm
just checking off the list
i have a day and a half of experience
now it's actually really fascinating and
it made me a better driver and i
actually have uh much more appreciation
of uh of the skill it takes to ride a
motorcycle it's not like a car
yeah no [ __ ] bill no but just [ __ ] that
you wouldn't think
like i didn't i didn't understand all
that went into just going around a turn
on a motorcycle
and how not only do you hit the do you
not hit the brake but if you hit the
brake you're actually gonna you know
you're gonna crash you gotta judge look
through the whole turn
judge your speed and then [ __ ] power
your way through it
um pretty intense
like i'm not gonna lie to you i'm not
gonna act like i would say i got this
this is easy
then we're going into the class and like
has anybody seen it and i'm getting
excited like wow
i just rode a bike for four hours i got
it up to third gear
down shifting this is [ __ ] great and
then i went into the class
and one of the things you know the group
discussion there was like anybody ever
see a motorcycle accident or been in a
motorcycle accident
it's like [ __ ] almost everybody or at
least half the class puts their hands up
and they start telling stories and this
one guys was like a paramedic
and he's going like yeah you know i saw
this uh guy was going like 90.
he hit a car head-on and his heart came
out of his chest
he had like all these stories
and i'm sitting there i'm like
like laughing to myself go what the [ __ ]
am i signing up for here
this is insane um
and then like the guy who was teaching
the class who looked like he was born on
a motorcycle and was [ __ ] you know
wrote the same way it was you know
obviously he's the instructor he's
[ __ ]
great at riding bikes he even had a
story of a couple months ago yeah you
know i hit some sand and i was like
saying you know i'm going over the
[ __ ] handlebars and i'm like keep my
body relaxed
and all i'm thinking in my head is it's
like dude you went down
you went down right
this guy i'm telling you it just looked
like he was just made to write a [ __ ]
you just had that i write a motorcycle
look as opposed to me
who looks like some douche who goes to
take a safety course and i'm just
thinking this guy went down
this guy's an emt talking about people's
hearts coming out of their chest i'm
just like what this is [ __ ] stupid
you know so uh
i don't i don't know where i'm at i
think i'm just gonna maybe just
ride on dirt is what i'll do you can't
you can't [ __ ] ride a bike out here
in l.a it's i
you know it is i'm old enough to know
it's [ __ ] stupid
so i think i'm gonna if i'm gonna do it
i just get like a dirt bike and i put it
in the back of my truck
drive out of the city and all the people
texting get to where the trail is and
then just ride around on dirt now i know
all you [ __ ] are gonna be like actually
most of the fatalities happen off-road
people not paying attention i know i
understand there's risk
with everything but uh
you know i don't know i think it's a
good thing that i waited till i was 45
to learn how to ride a motorcycle
because
if i was thinking if i was 21
then i would just i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
that's not gonna happen to me that's not
gonna happen to me like you get older
and by the time you're my age [ __ ] has
happened to you or some close friends so
you're kind of like yeah you know that
could happen to me
kind of like my heart in my chest on
this side of my rib cage
uh but i gotta tell you though i
definitely got the bug and
it's the most [ __ ] fun
i even by the second day i was actually
getting frustrated
because i was thinking like i just want
to take this out on the street
i'm sick of speeding up and slowing down
i just want to drive this [ __ ] thing
and uh i don't know
don't worry i'm not going to go out and
do that i'm not going to do that dumb
[ __ ] this is exactly
what a lot of people do when they when
they finally get to where they want to
be in life which is what i feel i am you
know
selling tickets as a comic get some
acting gigs every once in a while
you know you got a little free time what
do you do you pull it john denver you go
out and get a pilot's license
you know you fly some experimental
aircraft the next thing you know
in the news today singer songwriter
right so that's definitely in the back
of my head but um
i don't know i don't think nia is going
to let me get one anyways to be honest
with you that's probably a good thing
but you know what she did when she was
saying no she did the classic thing like
why do you want to
like you know have all these toys
what is it with guys and have you know
you you have your like what do i have i
go i got my truck she goes you get your
guitars and it's like
you're upset with me because i'm
enjoying life and she's like no
you know i think she just doesn't want
me to get one so she tried to do that
stupid argument that the motorcycle was
this
extension like it's like your dick like
you you
guys like it's between their legs and
they're riding this thing down the
street it's just like
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is about
when i was riding for the last two days
at no point was i thinking about my dick
other than thinking like i hope i don't
fall off
and uh when i'm going fast enough that i
get road rash on my dick
that would be the only thing other than
that you know what i wish i wish she
took the class with me
you know that's what i was actually
thinking it'd be great if she took the
[ __ ] class with me
and she would just see how much fun it
is it's fun
you know i don't [ __ ] know so uh i
got the bug now
i got the bug and i was looking at
motorcycles all last night so i was
telling her i said look all i wanna do
i'm just gonna get like the honda rebel
it's a [ __ ] 250 that's exactly what i
should get when i start out
if i get something else i'll kill myself
and she starts you know looking up those
stupid ducatis
which were cool about up until six
months ago and now every douchebag out
there has them
like everybody seems to have one of
those [ __ ] things so
you know i don't know and i looked at
the new harleys and i don't like them
i think they're ugly they kind of lost
their way they used to look meaner
so i'm just gonna if i'm gonna get one
i'm either gonna get a dirt bike or i'm
gonna get this little [ __ ] 250 i
think the speedometer only goes up to
like
70 or 80. um
i don't know tell me what do you what do
you guys think this is and this is going
to be one of those extreme
uh conversations and believe me i've
heard all the things get a motorcycle
you might as well buy the coffin to go
with it
it's not a helmet it's a brain bucket
i've heard all of that [ __ ]
um i don't know
just it does seem like a lot of fun
right you know if i if i get one i'm
gonna be one of those douche bags who
gets like a little 250 and i'll have
like all the gear on
i'll be dressed like alf samuelson if he
ever rode a motorcycle like completely
overprotected
[ __ ] robocop suit on and i just ride
around my neighborhood never never get
out of second gear
um anyway so that's what the [ __ ] i did
with my week
but you know it's good to know though if
i ever get chased by a bunch of
people with hatchets down the street and
i happen upon a [ __ ] motorcycle and
there's a little key there
provided it's not an old one with the
throttles on the other side or the
shifter or whatever the [ __ ] it is
i'll be able to i'll be able to escape
you know
all right i know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about okay everybody it's time
for a little bit of advertising
i know this is your favorite part of the
week well god damn it's mine too
bill's finally gonna stop babbling and
actually read something that's prepared
all right here we go um
okay e-voice everyone you're screening
calls
closing deals and making money all while
lounging poolside in the summer sun
thanks to who e-voice e-voice is a
better way to connect with people that
drive your business
e-voice will forward business calls to
your home mobile or any number you
choose
wherever you are e-voice will find you
don't have time to take a call it's
routed to voicemail
and you can read it at your convenience
as a text message e-voice not only gives
you an edge over your competitors it
takes away the edge the big companies
have over you right now
with e-voice you can create the
appearance of a whole office building of
departments
when customers call you a sales
department customer support
tech support you name it it's going to
sound like you have it all through the
wonder of e-voice
and it works with any phone even
yourself hey it's summer don't be stuff
stuck in the office all day free
yourself with the free
30-day trial of e-voice so you can see
what i'm talking about over here
go to evoice.com and enter the promo
code bill for your 30-day
free trial that's evoice dot com promo
code bill or go to the podcast page on
billboard.com
and click on the e-voice banner and uh
the next one tivo
tivo tim tebow before tevo watching tv
was weirdly had
you could only watch a show at a certain
time and if you missed it or even part
of it you literally had to wait for it
to go into reruns before you could see
it again
i could vouch for that i am an old man
tevo
totally changed all of that and while
other dvrs exist
they are not as sickalicious as tivo
because if you have
cable tivo lets you watch your shows
wherever you want
with tivo stream you can watch on your
ipad all over your house and even
transfer your favorite recordings and
take them with you
on an airplane waiting in line at the
dmv the dentist office t-vote makes
other dvrs look like they were designed
by some soviet comm
committee only tivo searches both cable
and web to find any movie any show
any video at the press of the button you
hear that both cable and the web
that's what sets them apart netflix
netflix
uh amazon youtube uh now those are just
like more channels on your tv
oh wow you can look at all of that
that's amazing and with the tivo mini
one tivo box works on a second tv from
the couch to the kitchen
from the minivan to 35 000 feet up in an
airplane tivo makes tv
about a thousand times better um
there you go all righty bing bang that
was easy wasn't it
all right let's get back to this so
anyway so i'm looking at the body issue
here and uh
i'm telling you to get inspired gary
player the guy's like 77 years old
i forget what he did five seven weighs a
buck fifty 55.
he's like at his high school weight
there he is there he is
who he is golfer pga tour winner
achievement award winner he's five seven
150 pounds
um i got to read this quote that he
didn't have to have
tattooed on his tattooless body here he
said a great man in india said to me mr
player
the less you eat the longer you live in
western society it's
eat eat plenty and die young i'm 70
vegetarian
this morning i didn't have any fats no
bacon no sausage no butter
but i'm a normal human being i have a
snickers if i want one
i'm not a martyr i mean dude you can't
if that's not something to aspire to
you know last time i was at
150 i was in [ __ ] i mean i'm taller
than the guy but
the guys at his high school wait you
know he can still
fit into his [ __ ] tuxedo that he wore
back in uh when he danced to benny
goodman
you know you know what's funny about
that vegetarian [ __ ]
you always fight it right you sit there
guy you gotta have some meat you gotta
blah blah blah blah but i gotta tell you
if you eat a giant salad every day
you're gonna be right as rain
you can eat a steak and afterwards you
can feel like you have a [ __ ] shoe in
your stomach you gotta take a nap
you know your body shuts down if you
have red meat and potatoes right
you know god damn well you got to take a
nap you literally have to [ __ ]
sleep it off you know you never have to
sleep off the salad people
um that's what i've learned as i've
gotten older just i got to stop fighting
it you know
i want the meat eaters to be right
does that make sense who wants to eat a
[ __ ] don't you want cheeseburgers and
fries to be the right way to go
of course you do but i'm telling you um
oh did i mention i
i finally ate a tomato out of my garden
my little modest garden dude
i i gotta tell you it was one of the
most [ __ ] unbelievable experiences of
my life
it was it was like i don't know what the
[ __ ] i was eating
for the first 45 years of my life um
i got to tell you do do it if you want
don't
this is great i i got tomatoes growing
right out in front of my house
cucumbers and peppers i'm on my way i'm
gonna have a bunch of [ __ ] veggies
growing out there
i know how to ride a motorcycle right
so i'll just have a bag of veggies
always ready to go
that's that's my uh that's my game plan
but the thing is is
if anybody on my block knows my game
plan
if they listen to this then all they're
going to do is just steal my vegetables
right and put some piano wire across the
street and that's going to be the end of
me
you know wouldn't that make sense
oh here you go i just got a text message
answering a question
i would have this tattooed on my body
hang on a second i've been playing a lot
of drums lately everybody
and i've been [ __ ] with that zeppelin
song in my time of dying
and i never know how to count it to
count it in for the
ba
you know when he starts off when the
[ __ ] drums come in
i never i i can't [ __ ] do i knew i
kind of thought it was maybe in 4 4 so i
got the answer here to all you drummers
out here
this is coming from a professional
drummer it's in 4-4
if you mean the big tom hits which i do
they are one
what they are one and of one
and of two
get the f so it's one and and is it i
thought was convinced
the guitar riff that opens the song
starts off on the end of four
oh that's what it is and one and two and
three
okay okay you [ __ ]
see that's the thing i loved about
zeppelin is they always did that little
tricky [ __ ]
so that da na na na na na na it starts
on the end of four and then okay
all right was that the most boring thing
ever to hear me trying to figure that
[ __ ] out
um all right what the hell was i talking
about
oh hey i owe a major [ __ ] apology
last week you know i have the apologies
every week
so last week i was talking about uh
i got to get his [ __ ] name here the
guy who won wimbledon
let me let me look this here wimbledon
2013 something murray right
what's his name here andy murray
and i said hey for the first time ever
congratulations the first time ever an
english guy won the [ __ ]
uh the wimbledon turns out the guy was
scottish
so right there i gave andy murray his
props
and instead of calling but then i called
them english which is a classic example
of what
that is some cold lotion i wanna hear
somebody send me some audio of that with
the [ __ ] scottish accent i apologize
to everybody in scotland
people in scotland can't stand english
people you know
actually most people in ireland can't
stand them either
they're not they're not a very
well-liked group of people
and you know why people are just hating
on them you know
just hating on them how [ __ ]
successful they are
with their kingdom right
great britain the english empire
they got you know something they're like
a franchise that got bought out
you know like remember back in the day
there was kinkos everywhere you went
and oh wait blockbuster they like the
blockbuster video of [ __ ]
empires actually every empire is after a
while you just get bought out by
something else
and i would say that uh our empire the
united states we're like blockbuster in
like 2006.
you know you see the writing on the wall
um so that's it right there you can't be
a tub of [ __ ]
it's coming to an end here people
something's gonna [ __ ] happen all
right so you gotta get your ass
in shape you gotta start growing
tomatoes and you gotta learn how to
drive
ride sail any [ __ ] thing that's out
there
um
ah i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] um i don't have
anything to talk about this week people
i'm not gonna lie to you
i got nothing okay usually i talk about
sports
oh i know what i can talk about in the
wonderful wide world of sports
did anybody see nelly going off on kobe
or discussing kobe
huh that's why i finally i feel
vindicated somebody else is seeing it
he's talking about the white howard
the white howard leaving going maybe he
doesn't want to play with kobe
and you know what's so funny stephen a
smith
is sitting there going blasphemy
blasphemy as
as he's as nelly his credit has the
audacity
to criticize kobe bryant that's why i
love stephen a smith because that's the
funniest thing he's saying blasphemy
like nelly is talking about the son of
god
that's how blinded stephen a smith is
about criticizing kobe bryant because of
his friendship with that guy
and protecting his interview stephen a
smith
i know you can't say it but come on
come on man you know you know the deal
kobe bryant
the in the history of nba basketball
there's never been another guy
who's gotten more help getting five
championships than kobe bryant
all right the same way the celtics piled
on in 2008
in the miami heat the last couple of
years kobe bryant every year he's on a
team like that
and i'm talking to my buddy jason
lawhead they're saying lebron the rumor
is he's gonna opt out
so is carmelo anthony and they're both
gonna go to la
how much more [ __ ] help does this guy
need
unfucking believable but like stephen a
smith
can you ever address this if you somehow
somebody sends this to you because i am
a huge fan
all right explain this to me
at the risk of you saying blasphemy as i
say this how a player
like kobe bryant can walk off the court
twice this year
during horrific losses walk off on his
own team
you tell me how that does not breed
resentment in the locker room
all right and how doing [ __ ] like that
all year
does not end up with your [ __ ] star
center saying i'm leaving
all right and i'm not saying that you
know
mr howard didn't [ __ ] fall short all
right i just hate saying dwight
it's dwight it's dwight howard dill
white
spell it d-u-h-white
all right um i don't know
all dwight howard has to do is just
steal a couple of moves from akeem and a
couple moves from kevin mchale and he's
gonna be [ __ ] unstoppable
and he had a look on his face like maybe
he was gonna commit to doing that for at
least four days
before he's gonna have that silly grin
look how pretty i am and look how big my
arms are i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
that he brings to the court every night
do you realize if you include stephen a
smith
that i just criticized about 40 foot of
uh human being
you understand that that could all kick
my ass i don't know about stephen a
smith i think i could take him to the
ground
choke him out with his tie who knows
blasphemy blasphemy
but uh that's one of the youtube videos
of the week you got to see that and then
i also have a great uh i was watching
the nhl network this week and uh
nhl network underrated they just you
know what they did
they just oh you know they just showed
every islanders clinching game
during their their four year dynasty
that they had from 80 to 83.
and uh i got this great clip
after they beat uh who do they be they
beat the north stars i think in 1980
uh when nystrom had that overtime goal
[ __ ] unbelievable pass too and uh
one of the sutter brothers had just been
called up
from the miners and they interview them
and it's just like
it's just was the most unsmooth ending
to an interview
the name of the youtube videos is good
luck we'll have that up there for you
too
and with that i've babbled enough here
let me uh
let me read a little [ __ ] ad here and
then we'll get into the questions for
the week sound good
well you don't have a choice because
that's how it's going down all right
dollar shave club everybody
all right this is why i like dollar
shave club because for years i've been
complaining about why do they treat like
disposable razor blades like they're
gold bullions
you know for some reason it's like 40
bucks for a pack they got a behind
glass you got to find somebody with the
key
you know the reason why you know why
people steal them
it's because they're horrifically
overpriced wouldn't it be nice
if someone was doing something about
that well i give you
dollar shave club all right
dollar shave club it's a cool brand and
they send you these quality radio uh
radios razors right to your door every
month you don't have to think about it
you don't have to wait in line
get someone to unlock the kick them from
the cage like i was just saying
and pay way too much money for a bunch
of features that don't even fit on your
old handle
shaving has become such a mess but not
with dollar shave club
you know what i'm part of this now it
saves me time and it saves me money
and the razors are great they're just as
good as any of that crap behind the
glass
you know except you don't have to go out
and get it if you want to try it go to
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr support this show go
to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bur
or click on the dollar slave shave
banner on the podcast page
at billboard.com once a month they're
going to bring you your blades you don't
have to think about it you throw out the
old ones and you have a nice smooth
shave
all month you don't pay too much for it
give it a shot
all right god bless you and god bless
the united states of america
okay let's get to the questions for this
week if i could find them
oh christ what did i do now what did i
do oh it was great i was talking i
wasn't stuttering this week i've been
reading copy
you know i feel like my copyright has
been good this week
all right okay water a day bill this is
in reference to your podcast and the
consumption of water
i fell off working i fell off working
out when i was working out
what why do you guys do this to me i
fell off working out but when i was
working out regularly i easily was
drinking a gallon and a half of water a
day
sometimes two two gallons
someone questioned question me on this
so i started to do research
and basically that's nowhere close to
the limit
humans can consump i consume i think
10 liters a day safely
is that what you think dude you can die
drinking too much water like
people please don't go out and drink two
gallons straight all right
uh he says thanks for the free comedy by
the way
that's what the reverse of colt
lotion thanks for the free comedy by the
way what's the reverse of cold lotion
like when you get a podcast out late
monday or tuesday
yeah we didn't get the podcast on monday
but guess what tuesday morning we're
going to have one
you guys will just never get beyond the
fact that the monday morning podcast
it's my monday morning it's 9 44 am
monday morning i'm recording this
okay all right i'm just like you guys i
see it in my world
it's my monday morning not yours go [ __ ]
yourselves um
you know what's funny is this guy's
sitting there like throwing out stats
here and then in the end he goes
um humans can consume like
i think 10 liters a day safely so
anybody listening to this
don't drink like i think 10 liters a day
find out how many you can have
and over what amount of what period you
know
look you can have 30 drinks in a month
but if you drink them right in a row
you know i don't think that's a good
[ __ ] thing so there's got to be a way
to
to to space it out right
i don't [ __ ] know all right all right
the truth behind jimmy's
last week i was talking about jimmy's
and i heard it was racist
the reason why you know so you call them
sprinkles or something
like up in boston the reason why they
call them jimmy's that was a reference
to jim crow
they've got a couple of jimmies over
there and then
a lot of the sprinkles being chocolate
in color
it didn't translate it over and this
guy's saying that i am wrong
all right bill love your podcast and
it's great to see you getting more and
more recognition
i'm from massachusetts and heard your
comment on the podcast about jimmy's
possibly originating as a racist term
this is a bogus myth and the history of
jimmy's is innocent
and actually philanthropic i can never
say that word
philanthropist if i whenever i see it i
can't say it
philanthropic i don't know
phil anthropic philanthropic
villain throw pick um so please don't
get sucked into these urban myths just
because you heard it from some idiot
[ __ ]
um seems that i've heard you blast these
types in your act anyways thought you
would find this interesting and go [ __ ]
yourself
the jimmy story is below there is
nothing racial about the name jimmy's
and there are no connection whatsoever
with the jim crow laws jim crow laws
were anti-african laws
that many uh southern states passed
following the civil war
and they had nothing whatsoever to do
with massachusetts now it wasn't
jim kroavs was basically separate but
equal and it was never equal
it was separate shittier but called
equal
correct is that what it is anyways um
here's the story
the brigham family of boston was in the
restaurant business in the early 1900s
in 1911 based on a bequest
a book quest not a not a request a
bequest
from the patriarch the peter brent
brigham hospital was founded it later
merged with the boston
lying in hospital and is now known as
the bringing women's hospital
three years later in 1914 a son edward l
bringham started the ice cream
restaurant in newton called brigham's i
remember that place
brigham's was the [ __ ] uh it later
became a chain of restaurants 1927
sydney farber graduated jesus christ is
it going to be this long
can i just tap out and say you're right
sydney farber graduated from harvard
medical school and became
a pathologist at peter
bent brigham hospital jesus this is too
[ __ ] long
in 1929 he became a resident pathologist
at the children's hospital meanwhile
1930 a candy campaign out of bethlehem
pennsylvania
dude can you just get to the [ __ ]
point
bethlehem pennsylvania called just born
introduced chocolate grains that could
be used as a dessert topping the man who
ran the machine that made the grain was
jimmy bartholomew so the grains the
grains became known as
jimmies you know everything was sounded
great you had all these dates and all
these long names of hospitals
and they like there was some guy named
jimmy
and he came up with them uh fast forward
to 1947 dr
farber established the children's cancer
foundation known as the dana farber
cancer institute
the next year 1948 dr farber established
a fund to raise money for children's
cancer
a 12-year-old boy named inair gustafsson
this is such [ __ ] at this point
these names are too long became the
poster boy
he attracted wide oh is this the jimmy
fund
um he attracted widespread attention
after a 1948
radio broadcast for the purpose of
keeping the boys enmity it was agreed
that the poster
boy should have a more all-american
sounding name
yeah because no one would care about an
enor gustafson
once you'll have your papers peter brent
brigham hospital where dr freber first
participated supported the fun
brigham restaurants also decided to help
raise money for the institute
by offering to put chocolate grains on
top of ice cream cones and sundays for
an extra penny
they got the grains from the just born
company which sold them as jimmy's
the penny went into the fund when you
got jimmy's the boy's nickname became
jimmy and the fun became known as the
jimmy fund
jimmy was a big fan of the boston braves
baseball team
today they are the atlanta braves holy
[ __ ] now we got the history of baseball
when the braves moved from boston to
1953 the red sox took over as the
sponsor
to the jimmy fund that's how the
sprinkles became known as jimmy's well
you know what sir
like if that isn't all true
that is the greatest filibustering ever
all right well [ __ ] it i'll call them
jimmy's again because you said so
another unknown [ __ ] who has a bunch of
dates with hospitals and all of that
and now you know the rest of the story
um jesus [ __ ] christ was that long
you know what's funny you heard all of
it now it would be great to see if you
could how much you could actually
remember and repeat
hey bill how did the name jimmy's come
along yeah there was a guy
who liked ice cream and he knew someone
in the hospital then a guy named
gustavuson got sick
and then there was a gma showed up with
the ice creams and
uh they were called jimmy's
there you go that's that's uh that's how
it came about
public service announcement for divorced
listeners hey bill
a couple weeks ago you advise divorce
guys to go to another city to increase
their chances of getting laid
by a good 40 percent did i say that
you know i'm just trying to fill an hour
i don't even remember saying that and
now that i've read it back it doesn't
even make sense to me
i concur oh okay i guess it does make
sense allow me to provide a public
service
to these guys and save them the trouble
of trying to figure out where to go
get to amsterdam gentlemen
i moved here four years ago from canada
and it's been insane
there are a couple of reasons for this
none of which has to do with weed or
hookers
though you can go that route if you want
reasons dutch women
gorgeous with bodies sculpted by a
lifetime of dairy products and riding a
bike
as a definite bonus they are
bored to death of dutch guys who have
zero game it's like negative game
they're all 14 year olds no sense of
humor no manners no flirting skills
nada wait a minute the whole country
there's not one guy who's
just kid slaying it there's always one
guy
in every grade there's a handful but
then there's that one the chosen one
that just has that thing anyways
whatever you and he goes as a foreigner
you're way ahead of these stiffs as soon
as you step
off the plane yeah that's true because
you have the accent you're from
somewhere different
tell me about winnipeg um
and it's not just the dutch chicks the
city is filled with hot european women
either on
on a weekend bender as a highly
impressionable intern because their own
country's economy is even
in a shittier place or is an expatriate
sowing their chick oats
it's a freaking gold mine uh you can get
here
you can get by here easily on english
everyone speaks it really well
throwing a couple of dutch words [ __ ]
that you can learn on the plane and
you've up your chances by another 30
percent
anyway there you have it boys uh
go [ __ ] yourself oh he said go freak
yourself canadian politeness
yeah you know that's something i wish i
knew back when i was a single man
just get your ass to a different country
and you're in inter
instantly you're interested you have an
accent
you know your clothes are a little
different a different perspective
you know you've seen that these [ __ ]
[ __ ] come over from me and i love
and they're like oh my god i love your
accent
they're sitting there with their [ __ ]
tight pants you can see their ankles and
their balls all at the same time you
know
um all right for the birds hey bill
i got these two parakeets my problem is
that these little dudes don't like me
uh i've tried whistling petting them i
don't know you can pet a bird
and squirting them with water
um do they like water i'm guessing that
that's a good thing parakeets like water
i don't know why don't we ask the
[ __ ] jimmy's guy to write a [ __ ]
nine pages on it
i love how i'm upset with that guy
because he actually did the research as
opposed to me who were like oh yeah i
overheard this in a bar
so anyways this guy's petting his birds
he's [ __ ] getting him with the water
hose
he's whistling at him
um all to no avail i know they're only
birds but i feel they hold a deep
resentment towards me well you clipped
their wings and you stuck them in a cage
how would you feel somebody cut your
[ __ ] nuts off
came by started whistling at you and
throwing water at you
you know i got an idea why don't you
leave him alone
would you open the cage right
why don't you take him to one of those
kardashian doctors and uh get a little
botox in their [ __ ] wings and let
them fly away
wouldn't that be annoying to you if you
were in a cage
your arms cut off at the [ __ ] elbows
and somebody came up and rather than
whistling they started speaking english
are you
speaking english at you um he goes i
think it's because i yelled at them
oh here we go because i think they
resent me because i yelled at them
what did you what what were they doing
uh i said no whistling during my shows
uh basically i had to scold them for
pooping in their water dish
but i had their best interest in mine
dude do you understand how [ __ ]
insane you are
that you feel like you can talk to a
bird
you know why don't you like not stick
the water dish
you know underwear that was it
underneath the swing
or what i would do is i just get a
bigger cage i'd get a bigger [ __ ]
cage
i put the water in the center that isn't
near any of those trapeze bars and
hopefully they won't be at the top of
the cage and still [ __ ] down on it
or i would accept the fact that it's a
bird in a cage
and that it's you know basically
anything at the bottom of the cage might
as well be the city of dresden
right i would just take that as part of
it i wouldn't yell at the birds
but anyways this guy he had to scold
them for pooping in their water
but i had their best interest in mine i
heard if they drink contaminated water
it can cause a disease that makes
all their feathers fall off well you
could also read up on it as opposed to
me who just repeat shits that they hear
he goes i do a lot for those little guys
but putting jackets on nude parakeets
isn't one of them even if i wanted to i
couldn't they don't even let me
pet them let alone dress them dude
you're not a bird guy
you should have got a dog uh he goes
when i originally
bought them i imagine i would have one
parakeet on each shoulder while hanging
out around my house but instead whenever
i approach the cage they freeze in
horror
every time they do that i can't help but
remember my brother's face
when he fell through the ice we had to
pull them out i thought maybe if i
bought them more toys they would
that would somehow help dude birds
motivation isn't more toys their
motivation is you not have an energy
like i'm gonna [ __ ] twist your head
off dude their wings are clipped so they
can't escape
you got them stuck in a cage they're
terrified and you yelled at them
i would say more than on one occasion
you yelled at them
all right um
you need to [ __ ] relax
all right listen to this would you would
you want to be
like your job to be in a cage all day
you know and then some you know
i don't know some giant comes home and
puts you on its [ __ ] shoulders
and your whole job is to enhance the
giant's [ __ ] life you don't
have a little bit of empathy for the
[ __ ] birds what i would do
is i would just have a totally relaxed
energy
and hope that they forget that you're
screamed at them
treat them nicely don't try to pet them
just don't [ __ ] with them every time you
come over they'll gradually be like oh
this is the guy who feeds us
this gal brings water this guy's on our
side
you know as opposed to the mixed
messages that you're sending them
um yeah and birds don't give a [ __ ]
about toys
you know do they i don't think they do
um he said i bought them a new toy every
friday on my way home from work and
there's a ridiculous amount of toys in
the cage and here's the kicker they
haven't played with the single one not
once
well dude do you look at the birds
outside
they're not out if you leave your
toddlers toys outside they don't go oh
good they left and then they go down
they start playing on his [ __ ]
tricycle
he goes they just stare at me i took
them to the vet but he spent more time
looking at his phone than the birds
anyways any advice would be greatly
appreciated
um i think you should find a bird lover
sir
and uh give the birds away and then um
i don't know i think you should get your
temper in check and before you and
before you do that yeah get your temper
in check and then if you want to
get a dog it seems like you want more
interaction with the pet
most people get birds because they can
have an interaction with an animal but
they don't have to walk it down the
street
and uh there's very a lot less
interaction with them you seem like you
want
a bird to act like a dog slash
a little kid like hey daddy's home i
bought you a fire engine
oh boy look at that does the bell work
you know somehow you want the bird to do
that
um yeah
please stop yelling at your birds all
right they can't help if they [ __ ] in
the water
you know they're birds they're not
supposed to be in cages
they fly around and they [ __ ] as they
fly
they [ __ ] when they're on branches when
they have to go they go
they don't have any stress they don't
have any shame
and there's water all over the place so
now you got them in this [ __ ] cage
with a little confined area of water
you know what what are they supposed to
do well
what do i know about the restaurant
business um all right
size issues oh jesus here we go again
here we go again maybe you need a
motorcycle all right
que pasa bilonardo hola
villanado que pasa ocho
uh we all know your disability
um to read pop properly
well you know what you don't even have
to write a sentence properly half of
this [ __ ]
is i get too far in front of myself and
the other half you guys don't know how
to write a [ __ ] sentence
we all know your disability to read
properly is that even written correctly
or am i a [ __ ] again we all know you
have a disability when it comes to
reading properly isn't that how it's
supposed to be
so i don't [ __ ] so i'm going to give it
my best shot to keep it
very short look at you coming with the
arrogance like
you have all light life figured out
right you got something tattooed on your
rib cage
um as you may have read the subject
title of this email you may already know
where this is heading yeah you seem
pretty cocky for a guy with a little
dick
um he says i recently got into an
argument with my girlfriend
who i've who i've been with for a little
more than two and a half years
where she told me that she wished i had
a bigger dick
ah man uh yeah that relationship is over
dude
that relationship is over one of two
ways
either one she's just trying to be so
[ __ ] mean to you that you break up
with her because she doesn't want to be
the bad guy
or she's just such a [ __ ]
self-involved human being that she
doesn't realize
like how mean that is they'd be like you
said yeah i like you i wish your tits
were bigger that would just be the
meanest [ __ ] thing why would you say
that to somebody
that you cared about that's a horrible
thing to say sir you know what you
started off as an arrogant [ __ ] now i'm
feeling bad for you
uh dude that's not the mother of your
kids
just take the dick out of the equation
what if you just said your nose is too
big that's just [ __ ] uh that's
that's that's just something a terrible
person says
she goes i was shocked to hear this and
didn't know what to say there's nothing
to say there's nothing you can do about
it
this is the first time she ever
mentioned my penis size also the first
time in my life by the way i guess
anybody's ever brought it up to be
honest
i don't know that i'm not well endowed
with my 5.5 inch rocket
you're a little below average sir i'm
not gonna lie to you now i'm being me
you know you can grab the rim but you
can't stuff at home if you know what i
mean
um and i did have little uh
have insecurities about it in the past
but learned to accept it and moved on
i never heard any of my former bed
partner girls complain
and the sex was usually great um
i know that it may sound ridiculous but
those few words were heartbreaking to
hear
and put a big giant stain on my
confidence yeah it's a terrible thing
that she said
i haven't felt like having sex ever
since and she made oh ever since she
made that remark
and i am afraid it's going to be a while
i haven't spoken to her
since the argument since i work a lot we
don't live together
i know it's a stupid thing to be upset
about no it isn't sir you're 100
in the right 100 the right and he goes
and i usually don't really care about
penis sizes
but but hearing that you're small from
your own girlfriend
is a whole other story i'm particular
typically not that guy that gets back in
her
by pointing out her physical flaws but i
don't know where
to go from here uh it's even been
difficult texting with her what do i do
bill got any advice okay you said you
don't know where to go from here
i can tell you exactly where to go right
out her front [ __ ] door
that's it it's a wrap sir it's a wrap
okay
now listen i'm not saying that she's
wrong
for wanting a bigger dick okay
like she needs more to satisfy her or
whatever or she just wants to go out and
bang some [ __ ] big dick dude
at this point all right
you know but her tact is wrong
okay you you accepted yourself which is
one of the greatest things you can do
that leads towards being happy every day
which leads you to treating the people
around you
respectfully which leads them to
treating you respectfully which leads to
more happiness
she [ __ ] with the core of your
happiness you know
you felt good about yourself she pointed
out something
and made you feel horrible about
yourself it's one of the worst [ __ ]
things she could have done
as far as mentally to you and and right
now the last thing you want to do
is go out and say the same thing to her
all right
if you really want to do just paraphrase
what the [ __ ] i just said
just just i don't know and i would just
leave it at that
and the childish thing to do this is
what you really want to get her back
just saying the challenges thing for me
to do would point out
some some of your physical flaws and the
great thing is is you leave it ambiguous
okay and i guarantee you she's going to
be in a bathroom mirror staring at
herself
if you want to get me okay
but um you know what this but i gotta
tell you something what's even better
you gotta have this what's known as the
self-esteem breakup
okay which you're totally in the right
here and you just say listen
all right what you said to me i felt i
used to feel good about myself
and what you said to me mess with the
core of my own my own happiness
and how i feel about myself
and that's not what i'm looking for in a
girlfriend
or a potential wife and uh
i just can't see you ever being a good
mother
if you would say something like that
just something along those lines i i
don't
i keep going mean don't go mean uh
whatever the [ __ ] i just said
i was just trying to paraphrase what the
[ __ ] i said but dude
this this is you should feel good about
yourself all right
you know you're not a porn star but
you're also you know you're not like uh
you're not what she's making y'all to be
here all right
that's it you still you're still in the
game sir okay you're not part of the
starting five hey neither am i
you know but you and i we come off that
bench okay we're the kind of guys
well the guys that go in the corners
right
uh yeah man that's that's you're 100
advice my advice would be
that this girl is is not anywhere near
the level of maturity she needs to be
and might never even get to that level
the only redeeming thing that i can say
to her is she has such a difficult time
doing what she wants to do in life that
maybe she wanted to break up with you
for a while and she didn't know how to
do it and was building up and then there
was just an argument and then she just
said that
or i don't know have you said anything
to her
i have no idea
oh it's funny he says uh thanks for the
weekly podcast you have no idea what it
means to me
see you in amsterdam well from what this
other guy was writing sir there's a
bunch of uh beautiful ladies out there
in amsterdam
um yeah dude the [ __ ] they're all riding
bikes they're in great goddamn shade go
on go get
go go find yourself a sweetheart all
right
all right there you go okay bulgaria
bulgaria everybody hey
there billy redface
um oh wait a second i gotta read the
last advertising here i'm sorry guys
we got a couple here we got a couple two
or three here
um oh i gotta do the last chunk here
last chunk
all right where am i going legalzoom
everybody
most americans don't have a will but why
you guys all have stuff right you don't
want somebody you don't like getting
your stuff do you legalzoom.com
everybody
you don't want the government rules
dictating what happens to your property
and minor children you don't so why
procrastinate most people say too
expensive
too time-consuming i don't want to deal
with it man
my answer is legalzoom.com too expensive
you're going to love legalzooms
reasonable prices
too time-consuming most people finish
the online process
in just 20 minutes and we're not talking
some fill-in-the-blank forms
uh your will is state specific and
personalized based on your information
best of all legalzoom has 12 years of
experience helping people with important
legal matters
it's national make your will month
people
so don't wait any longer go to
legalzoom.com and get 15
off your last will but this offer ends
soon or get a living trust
and you'll receive a uh poor over will
absolutely free
uh to get your special discount be sure
to enter bur in the referral box
at checkout for wills powers of
attorneys trusts and more go to
legalzoom.com
legalzoom can provide self-help services
at your specific direction or connect
you with an attorney
but they are not a legal firm all right
stamps.com everybody there's nothing
instant about getting postage from the
post office driving there
parking it's a waste of time so you use
stamps.com instead
instantly get postage for any letter or
package right from your own desk
stamps.com is so quick and easy to use
that even a [ __ ] like me can use it
buy and print official us postage using
your own computer or printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
that automatically calculates the exact
postage you need
they'll even help you decide the class
of mail based on your needs
no guesswork plus it's convenient take
care of your mailing and shipping
wherever you need to
24 7 right from your own desk you'll
never have to go to the post office
again
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
i have never
repeat ever had a problem uh right now
use my last name burr for the special
offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus that includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage
type in bur b-u-r-r that's stamps.com
enter bur
and finally
hulu plus everyone um i'm sure you've
tried hulu.com
i'm sure you're a fan but i want to tell
you about the newest
latest hulu hulu plus hulu plus lets you
watch thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere
streaming on your tv or go to your
smartphone or tablet
why stand in line or ride a train and
just stare at your feet
you could be watching your favorite
shows on hulu plus hulu plus is a great
way to binge watch your favorite shows
i'm gonna use hulu plus to catch up on
the old family guy episodes i've missed
when i was on the road
or rockford files or whatever the hell
else i want to watch
or maybe all the lord of the rings
wouldn't that be phenomenal
didn't see an episode a new girl that's
on hulu plus two
and if i ever decide to watch lost hulu
plus is the place for that
if i ever want to watch 90 hours of lost
i could do it on hulu plus you get the
point it's only 7.99 a month everybody
7.99 for all the shows and movies you
can watch
catch up on current shows binge on old
and favorite new shows
it's great you can do it all on hulu
plus right now you can try hulu plus for
a couple of weeks for free
on me when you go to the podcast page at
billboard.com
click on the hulu plus banner or go to
huluplus.com okay
there you go everybody and that right
there is all the advertising for this
week
um all right where am i going here back
to the question bulgaria everybody
hey there billy redface i heard you ask
about bulgaria
in eastern europe i've traveled around
europe over the last five years and
bulgaria is very
nice plus they love americans serbia is
pretty nice too
they don't love americans like the bulks
but uh
it's still safe even though we bombed
them in the 90s they even have a pretty
good sense of humor about it
and if they know your american your
american perfect strangers
will walk oh if they know you're
american there should be a common
comma there perfect strangers will walk
to you and ask what
and ask the question why did you bomb us
and even they settle
celebrate a battle they lost to us well
if they came up to me and said why did
you bomb us
i would be like i wasn't even aware we
did that
what happened uh that would make it even
worse
they even celebrate a battle they lost
to us serbia serbia has been very
commercialized over the last 10 years
and there is a strict code of
masculinity amongst the men kind of like
americans
plus i don't even know what that means
plus the exchange rate
is great all over the former yugoslavia
and instead of booking a hotel you can
rent a very nice apartment for a month
and it would actually be cheaper and
nicer than a hotel because there's no
first or less
or at least as long as you have cash and
a place to crash stay away from romania
the only good thing i heard about that
country is the country
which is beautiful in the summer the
rest of the year it looks like
appalachia i don't even know what that
means
i don't i don't know what that is
appalachia
um i always feel like if i'm going to
get kidnapped in europe i always feel
like it's going to be in eastern europe
i would think of that and you never hear
anything about bulgaria what the what
the [ __ ] did we do
i need to know this we can be dropping
bombs on people in a bad way
we bombed serbia was that when the other
croatia the serbians bosnia heard the
govinda
they were all [ __ ] battling with each
other that's when yugoslavia and
czechoslovakia
became independent of russia and now
they didn't have a common enemy in the
russians because they had pulled out
after like 1990 and then they instantly
picked up on these wars that had been
gone for like 90 years
isn't that what happened ah jesus
yeah america
bombs serbia
nato bombing of yugoslavia all right
reason why i hate usa america bombing of
serbia
that's a video oh bill clinton oh yeah i
remember that
oh didn't he bomb them because he
[ __ ] was figuring that
[ __ ] refrigerated-faced
[ __ ] mess of a woman you make me feel
like a younger man
can i stick this cigar in your [ __ ] um
the nato bombing of yugoslavia was
nato's military operation against the
federal republic of yugoslavia during
the kosovo war the strikes lasted
from march 24th 1999 to june 10th my
birthday
1999 the official nato operation
well code was operation allied force
yada yada yada
goals nato's objective in the kosovo
conflict were stated
in the north atlantic counties means
well yeah and i imagine they said it was
something about freedom but it was
really about some sort of
natural resource or power um
strategy what the [ __ ] is it come on
let's get to the
what was her name margo adams what was
the name of that poor that unfortunate
woman
you know naval
civilian you don't want to look up bill
clinton bombs
yugoslavia
wait marco adams was the [ __ ] chick
that
uh what's his face banged from the red
sox
the hell was his name there he's always
wade boggs
bill clinton bombs
yugoslavia
what the hell was your name it wasn't
margo
began with an m what the [ __ ] was the
name of that what he stuck that cigar in
a thing i can't remember
a [ __ ] name
uh i'm just gonna stick cigar bill
clinton bombs yugoslavia cigar
let's see if that comes up
bill clinton what really happened
u.s bombing killed 224 people
why clinton bombed the serbs all right
here we go
oh that's just that's just too long you
know what i don't know why he did it
but clinton did it he did it 1999. i'll
just look at the ground yeah sorry about
that
sorry we uh sorry we bombed you
ah jesus christ all right well that's
the podcast for this week everybody i
know it was kind of all over the place
um at this my life uh this is the
wrap-ups for the show here now that the
show's over don't forget to support all
the sponsors
or just one of them anything you can
support okay
we got you know you can get your uh well
done at legal zoom
you get your voice e-voice things
e-voice uh
gives you a toll-free number so you can
take business calls from anywhere
sound in the office you remember it i've
already talked about this stuff
uh now the show's over you got hulu plus
you can binge on all those shows
if you don't like them you can check out
tevo right
give you two options you know you don't
want to buy shave go to the dollar shave
clubs you don't want to buy the blades
i hate these [ __ ] wrap-ups you guys
heard all of this [ __ ] before that's it
i'm not doing the wrap-ups go [ __ ]
yourself
um all right that's the podcast for this
week okay
coming up this week why am i shouting i
am going to be friday night
i'm gonna be in boise idaho saturn eight
saturday night bozeman montana
if both those shows are not sold out
they're damn close
uh that's this is the beginning of the
red state tour and
uh then right after that then i have to
do my acting gig
and i never tell you guys much about the
acting gigs because uh so many guys i
know
get into movies or whatever and then
they tell people they're in them and
then they get cut out or whatever so
i wait till it's in theaters when it's
in theaters and i'm
actually in it then i tell you i'm in
the movie that seems to be the best way
to go about it but i know there's a lot
of
you people out there where you would go
hey you know you're supposed to be
coming to my [ __ ]
flyover state and now you're not what's
the deal
well um the shows have not been canceled
they have been rescheduled
okay so the first two stay the same
uh boise state july 26 and the emerson
center for the
uh for the arts theater in bozeman
montana is july 27th those are still the
same
el paso has been moved um
i got to change that date on my website
but right now uh colorado
boulder colorado the new date is
september the 4th
september the 5th is the first day of
nfl football
i'm going to try to go to that because
i'm going to be out there in colorado
september 6th pikes peak center colorado
springs
and then okay el paso has been moved to
september 12th
okay we keep going we keep going and
then um
in november i don't have the dates up
here on my site yet in november
those are going to be the deadwood
uh tulsa oklahoma wichita kansas dates
will be in november
and uh for those of you asking about my
um european tour
these dates are already on sale december
5th in amsterdam
december 7th in london december 9th in
dublin december 11th
copenhagen denmark december 12th oslo
norway
december 13th i'm in stockholm sweden
and rumor has it this is confirmed
i'm going to be in iceland that's going
to be the last one
i'm going to be in reykjavik arikovic
however the [ __ ] you say it
and uh oh [ __ ] i just thought of
something else
the hell was i going to say
you know what i just totally spaced
i don't [ __ ] know anyways i'm going
to be over there and other dates coming
up are helsinki
i'm also going to be in glasgow scotland
and uh i think that's it
that'll be it those are all the
countries i'm hitting i
iceland ireland scotland england norway
sweden
finland copenhagen
and uh the netherlands so there you have
it all right
with any luck i'm gonna go to italy
right before i do my tour
i'm gonna sit there anybody has any
advice anybody listen to this podcast
over in italy
where should i go what should i do i got
like three days i've never been there
should i go to rome first
should i see the colosseum and if i'm
there where should i eat
because i know everybody out there is
going to be like we got the best
and they don't i want you to tell me
where it's at all right
that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves
and uh and that's it i'll talk to you
next week all right
you